Shh this is really important because
we've been learning this stuff and one
of the most important things of all in
all of mathematics is connecting new
knowledge to old knowledge okay now
you've been looking at tables like this
in the questions you're doing right this
is what we call a frequency distribution
table because it tells you the frequency
and how its distributed they now that
right okay so this is an example of a
frequency distribution table we're
looking at some temperatures okay now
what I want to do is connect this
frequency distribution table to
something we did last year a probability
distribution table now in all likelihood
that's evacuated your mind since the end
of last you so I want to reach in your
back okay now remember if you want to
work out a measure of central tendency
like say the mean okay if you want the
mean then you're gonna have to add up
stuff and divide by by however many
things you are right so you can see here
N equals 16 of atom all up ok and then
after that and I want you to look
carefully look runway this is how I
would calculate the mean for this set of
data okay I say there are two days that
had 27 degrees there are three days they
had 28 six they had 29 degrees and so on
add it all up divided by sixteen you get
a mean you're happy with that so this is
not rocket science oh you've just been
doing this okay but how does this
connect to what we're doing last year
you can take the same frequency
distribution table and you can convert
it look carefully
Tyler you two look carefully you can
convert it very simply into a
probability distribution table same
values but look at what I've done same
same temperatures right what's what's
going on here what does 1 over 16
represent it's the chance right of of
picking out this day that's 31 degree
day out of all of them ok now when we
were looking at probability distribution
tables that's a mouthful we didn't talk
about means we talked about something
else it started with an age is an owner
remember close with 3 mething that
summarizes the whole thing all together
in a single number
and remember it's actually two words we
talked about getting an expected value
out of this do you remember that is this
variable now how do you do it well this
is how I'll show you right what you do
is you take each value temperature and
you multiply it by its probability and
then you just add them all up remember
that Sigma notation right so this is
what you get now hold on a second
when you go ahead and calculate this you
get the same number the mean and
expected value now why is that I got one
last one to show you so you can see the
connection
look carefully I'll zoom in just a
little bit more okay this is how we
calculated the mean right we said oh I
had two lots of 27:3 lots of 28 I add
and mall up and then finally I divide
yeah but now look that divided by 16 is
what you had to do to turn each of these
into a probability right like 3 out of
16 is a probability so that's why it's
exactly the same calculation just in
slightly different order so I want you
to think about expected value and the
mean as parallel ideas it's just are you
dealing with frequency or probability
does that make sense
thank you everyone